- Can you imagine getting a blowjob
and a girl trying to put
a condom on you first.
Has that ever happened?
- I did have one girl that she was like,
I'm going to blow you,
put a flavored condom on.
I was like, why?
She goes, because I don't like the taste.
I was like, well you think
your pussy taste like Skittles?
What are you fucking talking about?
- What! Are you out of your mind, Yeah.
- Because she didn't like the taste?
- Taste of dick,
apparently she didn't like
the taste of dick in her mouth.
- What flavor did you have her?
- I was like no, I'll just not have
the blow job then.
- Yeah.
- Like I don't want my dick
sucked through a condom.
Like, it's just...
- That's so weird.
- It's the shit version.
That would be like eating
like eating a plastic apple.
- Why would you want to suck anyone's dick
if you didn't like the taste?
Why, what is?
- Yeah! Nobody's sucking
dick for the taste.
- Yeah, no one's doing it for the taste,
or like, you're not doing it for anything
except you put all those things,
that's what I'm like...
The idea of cum, when
you find out about cum,
it's like something you're going
to have to encounter as a woman.
It's horrifying to you,
and then you encounter it,
and you're like its not great
- It's part of the deal!
- I don't understand women who
consistently go like (blah).
It's just like if you're
going to encounter it,
lean into it bitch!
(punk rock music)
- Most hookups aren't that interesting
- Yeah.
- and you can't really
conjure all these like,
this imagery that I kind of wanted.
- But what do you want to
hear? Like, what are you
looking to hear that would turn you on?
- Just like a guy, just like
whenever he would just like go for it
with a girl, she would be like oh my god.
Like that kinda thing.
- You know what's the hottest thing
that ever happened to me?
I was like a licensed physical
therapist and like ...
- That doesn't sound hot.
(laughter)
- I know, dude.
- The fact that you're licensed.
- Dude, it sound like
you're about to tell me
about a crime you did.
- No, no, no, this woman
came in with tennis elbow.
- Here's how I got fired.
- She just came in, which is
like not a it's tennis and I,
she was like a hot,
recently divorced woman and
I was like extremely professional,
like I was just massaging her elbow,
and then she was just like,
look, I'm just going to say this,
I want to get on my knees
and suck your dick right now.
- Wow, you have her golf mouth?
(laughter)
- And I was just like...
- Wait, what did you do?
- I swear to Christ and I was just,
I was like twenty-three years
old, twenty-four years old.
- Was she hot?
- She was really hot!
I just, first of all, I was like in khakis
and I just got an instant
boner through my khakis.
Just like, I couldn't hide it,
it was like sticking out of my pocket.
And then I was like
well it's like illegal.
And she was like that's
why I want to do it,
it's what turns me on.
She was like I promise you, like,
I'll write on a piece of paper right now
that I won't say anything,
she was like I really just wanna do it.
She's like, I actually need to do it.
And she was like,
- I love this woman
- Just lock the door.
- Oh my god.
- Yeah and then it was,
she, it was literally
- Does this end with
you getting a blowjob?
- Yeah, this literally ends with me
getting a 10 second blowjob
because I just couldn't hold it in,
like she literally gave like two pumps
and I was like I'm done.
- And what did she do?
Was she happy, she was ecstatic?
- Nothing, she went "Mmm," I swear.
- Ah my elbow just clicked, that's amazing
its the cure to all my problems
- And then I said
do you want me to
continue with the massage?
And she was like yeah I
have numbness in my arm,
and then she came back and I didn't know
I told my boss what
happened, and he was like
oh my god yes,
(laughter)
I thought he was gonna be like
we have to call the state boards,
- Why did you tell him?
- He was like did she send you
any pics, and I was like no
- Can you refer at your made,
I gotta send this to the
higher ups this is the
worst tennis elbow I've
ever seen in my life
(laughter)
- Let me look at those x rays
- I'm gonna need to bring
in another consultant
Jerry! Jerry!
- I remember he was like fuck,
he was like damn I was
gonna take that patient
but I gave it to you but I
remember he was like 300 lbs
he had like a ketchup stain on his shirt,
I'm like okay
- He's just thinking
that it was for anyone
- And then she treated her
maybe 2 or 3 more times,
and then she messaged me on Facebook
this is like 10 11 years
ago and she was just like,
she wanted me to come over
and just have sex with her
and we did that maybe 3 or 4 times
- You did go?
- No we did that maybe 3 or 4 times
- If this is how you met
the mother of your child,
I swear to fucking god
- No she doesn't play tennis
- And then it all just stopped one day
she stopped messaging me
and then I looked on her
Facebook maybe a year later
and she was like remarried
to either her old husband
or a new guy
but it was just like that,
I couldn't believe like
when she said that,
I thought I was having a
hallucination or a stroke
or something like that, my
heart pounded I was like
what's wrong
- Its so whoreish, its so cool
I think that woman's so cool
- I've had things happen
to me where you just go,
when you're telling the story you just go,
I know you're not going to believe this
because I don't even believe this
I got a foot job on a plane once.
- What? What? What?
- A foot job?
- How did it start get us through this
- I'm gonna tell you this,
I also do not believe
this fucking happened,
this is my story and it
fucking happened to me
- Okay
- My flight to the UK from
Chicago was fucking delayed
- Chicago
(laughs)
- They got me a new flight,
I go to the business lounge
they're like sorry for the mix up,
I got absolutely shit faced
in the fucking lounge,
I get on the plane
- What airline?
- Oh god,
- Spirit
- British airways
- British airways that's
a foot job airline
(all agree)
american you'd get a blowjob
- I'm just trying to figure
out how you were sitting,
yeah yeah well figure it out
- Spirit you dry hump
(laugh)
and you pay
- 9 dollars
- United is a hand job over the trousers
but you have to give it
(laugh)
its not for you
the flights fucking empty, I'm shit faced
British airways steward comes down,
and this is the bit where I know,
she was Philippino,
- Were you in first class?
- No, no, no, economy, right
sat there, me and her middle isle,
and the guy comes down and
I'm like ill have a red wine
and she's like ill have champagne,
he's like its an empty
flight have two each,
we ended up getting really, really drunk,
not saying a word to each other
- Wait you have an isle between you?
- No, no, no, no, like were center row
its me, her to my left, empty chair, bloke
- Okay
- And beside me across
the isle a family of 3
- Okay got it
- But then a lot of emptiness
on the rest of the plane
- Yeah, yeah, yeah
- Just a busy row
- The lights go off, I'm watching a movie
were very drunk, and just
this hand that's not my hand
comes under the thing and
starts jerking me off,
and I'm like what the fuck is happening,
I look over and she's
not making eye contact
she's just jerking me off
under this fucking thing
and I'm like okay cool
like I'm fine with this
this is great
right, I jizz everywhere,
on the fucking blanket
I have to cram it under
the fucking thing in front
- Of course
- Wait she put her hand, I
thought you said foot job?
- Oh oh we get there
- Yeah its a long flight
- What movie
- I thought it was like a
different term in the UK
- I was watching the blindside
Sandra Bullock, while a
woman molested my bullocks,
- I mean you always remember
whatever you're watching
when you're getting fingered
or somethings distracting you
kind of just zone out and
you're not real watching it
but you can have the memory of it
- Yeah, I can't watch the
blindside anymore without getting
a huge boner,
people are like
you really like that black
kid that plays football,
I'm like I'm really
sorry it does it for me
(laughs)
- Okay get us to the foot
- Then she sort of laughs
and I'm there like okay
just processing what happened
and then 30 fucking minutes
later I feel my buttons on
my trousers getting undone
and I look there and her hands are there
and its with her fucking
feet she's leaning over
I'm like I've never had
a foot job in my life
but the dexterity of
this woman was impressive
she gets it out with her feet
she gave me a full foot job
- What
- You came again?
- I had to ask for a second
blanket I was like I spilled
on the first one, right
she gave me a second one I had
to cram it under there again
- There's too blankets now?
- He's bending poppadoms the
second I'm off the flight,
she does it again I'm just laughing
I'm steaming drunk she's
clearly very fucking drunk
I fall asleep instantly,
for the remaining 7 hours of that flight
- Did she have to kind of
scoot over to the other thing
- This is how she's doing it
- What about the bloke next to her?
- Asleep
- So she had 2 seats to work with
- Yeah, yeah, yeah
but she just fully started,
she was watching the movie
she did not make eye contact
with me at any point.
- What?
- Wow
- You're causing a divorce right now
- I remember going to
the bathroom afterwords
and just looking at myself in the mirror
and just laughing
and just saying the words to myself
nobody Is ever going to believe you
because I still to this day
don't believe it happened,
- Yeah, yeah
- And it fucking happened to me
- Did you say bye when the plane landed
- This is the bit where I'm a monster,
she's like where are you going
I'm like I'm going to
Scotland where are you going
she goes I'm going to Norway
she was like what terminal
I was like terminal 3
she was like same shall we just hang out
I was like I fucking owe
you breakfast minimum
- Of course
- Absolutely
- Like thank you for the greatest thing
that's ever fucking happened
I was 23 at the time
- 23 great age
- She was like 35
- But wasn't yours 23
- Yeah, 23
- The best age
- And when I was getting the
blowjob I remember Celine Dion
was playing on the radio
- Exactly, you remember
like you sense memory
- When I was 13 I jerked off
on a school bus by myself
- Yeah dude
- Is this just your excuse
about why you get turned on by
school buses
- Whatever the short ones especially
(laughs)
- Officer the reason I'm masturbating
is because when I was 13
- You had a thing happen to
you when we were at the airport
you went and got a massage
and that woman straight
up rubbed all over you
- Yeah she was definitely
doing a little extra
- So she put his hands
behind his back to do the
like shoulder blade thing
and then rubbed her vagina
on his backward facing palm
as she was giving the massage
I was having a conversation
with him getting a manicure
while this is all happening
- I was getting a manicure too
- He was behind me and we
were just talking like this
- She gave me one of these
and just started like
rubbing her pussy on my hands
- I was like I love that lady
- Then I went back to get another massage
because our flight got delayed
and I see her doing it to
another guy I felt so used
(laughs)
using all these hands
- I thought I was special
- She had like a tattoo on her neck
that came from under her shirt
like a tree of life of some sort
- Yeah
- No I've never had
something that hot in public
- I mean you've also gotten
hand jobs before from
- Whatever you know
- That's just what happens
- You know it happens
- At massage parlors
- Yeah just one time in college
and post grad
and after that
- Did you fill out your punch card
did you get one free after
- Yeah after 9 they actually
throw you out the window
and say you're a dirty piece of shit
(laughs)
yeah its pretty cool
- I'm fascinated
- You're next one free
I thought they were all free
- Let me just tell you,
every guy is going to
these jerk off parlors
at least a couple times they all go in man
- I've never been and I've never
hooked up with a prostitute
but I should do it
but I know all my friends that do, do it
its just like a safe way to
cheat and not feel bad about it
and just get stressed out and
then its just like thank god
those things do exist
because some guys would just
implode without it
- Yeah I went and got a
massage and this woman was
definitely down to do some stuff to me
and I didn't realize it until later
and I was kind of piecing it all together
on the show I was like I
think I went to a prostitute
and I was like why isn't that for girls
- They do have it for girls though
- Also because it takes longer
at the end of your massage
and for a bloke their like
this is going to take 2
fucking minutes
but with a guy like
fucking hell you've got to
light some candles,
get Celine Dion playing
- Do you have my comforter, yeah
- Do you have my teddy
bear from when I was 7
- 35 minutes in, is this good for you
kiss my neck
- Not that one
like it take forever you're right
I was joking about if I tried
to like Louie ck someone
- A hand job is 1% of the fucking massage
whereas to frig a girl to
the point where she cums
is 50% of it
- But you can be trained
in it to get it done
pretty like well,
there should be like ane efficient
way to do it that's tough
- Theo von he had that
- Orgasm meditation
- Yeah he was like certified
and he would just go over
and give women orgasms
they would just let him in
there's no speaking its
like this professional thing
they would specify if they
wanted him to use a glove or not
and he would just get them off
- And then leave
- And then pay them and leave
- I mean it sounds like a great system
- I know sounds like the life
- But I've had it done to me
because my ex boyfriend took the course
I was like into him
hooking up with other girls
so he's like oh ill take this
course and that'll be cool
then he went to it and he
was just like your just like
fingering like kinda gross
- Like old women
- Yeah like its not a hot thing
- Its never Jennifer Lawrence
- Recently engaged Jennifer Lawrence
- Oh I know congratulations
to Jennifer Lawrence,
- Who's she getting engaged to?
- A guy in the art world
- They get all the pussy
- Which is so awesome
- I remember one of my friends
like there was a report
she was single 2 years ago
he was like I'm going to
dm her I'm like good luck
- She's a friend of
mine, and she is someone,
a normal guy got through
is what I'm saying,
- So a guy who's a baggage
handler for jet blue
do you think, that's the
guy who said my boy Debo
thought he could message her
- Hilarious
- Literally he bet, he's a
baggage handler for jet blue
he was going to dm her,
because when he talks women
he says he's a pilot,
so he's going to say he's a jet blue pilot
he's 5 foot 3
and has Mets tattoos all over his body,
- That makes me feel so good
- So thank you for giving him hope.
For saying she's a nice girl
a normal guy can get through
I should of let him fucking send it
- His lie could be anything though
but he's like what's a step up
from baggage handler, a pilot
- For jet blue
- Yeah
- He's in that world he
knows maybe enough to fake it
that makes me feel better
because there's some guys
that shoo their shot with me on Instagram
and I go to their thing and
I'm like what makes you think
I would be into you,
and you live,
okay lets take distance out of it,
but like its you just wouldn't,
I always take it as an insult
almost, like you think,
really is that what you think of me
- Do you think my standards are your low?
- You've had that happen
to you with girls before
- Yeah and then I fuck em
(laughs)
- Well its different with us
- Equal opportunities I respect that, yeah
you and J Law peas in a pod
- You're on private without
a picture, yeah ill fuck you
- Oh my god that private thing,
if girls were sliding in guys dms,
you've got to make your
profile on private,
I'm not going to like,
if I can't see you I'm not
going to even entertain the idea
of going out with you its
all based on looks initially
- That's another thing I stopped doing,
I stopped responding to
everyone on Instagram
I used to respond to everyone
hours of my life would accumulate
so now its just like I have
however many unread dms
and if I feel so much better
about not reading them
then when I would ready
every single one of them
and respond to every single one of them
- I comb through them
sometimes just to see if any
blue checks make their way in
- Oh then you've got to open it up
- I'm a big fan of the Instagram dms,
because after my Netflix
special I was going through
them lets just see what
I'm available to get
- Oh my god yeah
- Two lesbians from Texas
flew to London to fuck me
- What?
- Two lesbians from Texas
flew all the way to London
they're like well pay
- That's a country song right there
- Yeah (laughs)
its a Dolly Parton I think
- Two lesbians from Texas
- Wait they flew in and you fucked them
- Yeah absolutely of course I did
- They were into you?
I mean they're lesbians
so they're bisexual maybe
- Yeah bisexuals
- You have a feminine look to you
- I beg your pardon
- No like a strong feminine,
like a good looking man
- Tell me how this went down
so you knew they were coming to town
- Oh I was fully prepared
to be fucking murdered,
like I was like I will absolutely
take this fucking gamble
they were like we just saw your special,
we didn't break up,
we wanted to put our
relationship to the test
if we fly to London will you fuck us,
I was like yeah of course
do you think I'm an idiot
of course ill do that.
And the whole time
- Did you know what they looked like
- Yeah yeah I full checked and everything
I texted my friends
before I went to the hotel
I was like if I get murdered just like,
its not a sad story,
- You went out doing what you loved
- Yeah, yeah, yeah he
died doing what he loved,
lesbians,
- From Texas
- It was fucking excellent
I went to the hotel room,
they were like shall we do this,
I was like yes please
spent 2 days with them
- And they paid for their
flight you didn't have to pay
for this
- 2 days?
- I mean I had to buy them both dinner,
- Yeah that's nice
- During room service,
while they were servicing me
in the room its great,
two days I spent with them
just in the hotel room just
fucking the shit out of
each other
- That's so fun
- Great
- I'm always like scared
though that what if you
get there and they
smelled weird or something
- I made sur before I went
there, I made fake plans
so like hey I might have
to do this thing later on
it depends
- Yeah all these outs
- I'm waiting on my agent to text me
- And then everything falls
through you're like wow
that's weird
- And then I text my agent
do not text me for the next
2 fucking days
- Oh my god
- I'm like no matter what,
if they want a fucking movie
- When you're preparing for a threesome
are you not jerking off for
like a week before that,
like are you gearing up for that
- I was
- You take a Viagra, what do
you do going into these things
- No I've had threesomes
I was just like this is
too good to be true I'm
going to get murdered
I walk into the room you look everywhere
for a camera
but even that if you want to film me
having a fucking threesome, great
- Did you use a condom
- Nah
- Nice
(laughs)
- You can't put on a condom
in the middle of a threesome
- Well its exhausting
wait one second you, you know
- I trust them, they're
married you're not gonna
have diseases
- Well yeah you could wear
1 condom for both of them,
- Nobody in a marriage has
a disease come on, its 2019
(upbeat music)